[Music]
as states moved to lift school mask
mandates cbs evening news anchor and
managing editor
nora o'donnell spoke with a group of
moms juggling the changes starting march
12th california oregon and washington
state will no longer require masks in
schools and new york is dropping its
mask mandate tomorrow and as norah
o'donnell shows us parents are also left
with difficult decisions she speaks with
four mothers in virginia where the
governor recently signed a law giving
parents the right to decide whether
their children should wear masks
raise your hands if your child will
still wear a mask
why would they still wear masks so we
actually talked about this i asked my
kids would you like to continue to wear
a mask they're like mom of course we
want to we don't want to get covered we
don't want to get sick we don't want to
pass it along my husband and i talked it
through and we felt that we would
transition off of mass gradually will
your
son wear a mask he is extremely excited
to be able to not wear a mask at school
he
loves to smile at people do you think
this issue
about kids in school coveted in school
masks or no masks ends up driving a lot
of people to the polls on both sides
i think so i don't think that this
started politically at all i think that
this was
people weighing their individual
circumstances
trying to do what's best for the
community how those choices were
impacting their families i think what
politicians have done as they've come in
and they've realized there's an
opportunity here to drive this and jump
on one bandwagon or another and exploit
people's fears exploit or capitalize i
think on these issues and on these very
emotional and often very personal
decisions and so i think that it has
made this so much more divisive than it
really needed to be moms are mad
about this
i do think moms are mad some dads too i
don't want to say it
but parents who feel that the school
system did two things right you can't
divorce the child care aspect from it
and also it provided a really solid
education and both of those things were
put seriously at risk during the
pandemic and then i think there's this
sense that the education that was
provided
during the pandemic somewhat by
necessity wasn't as high
high quality is what we would want and
we need to now confront that and i
personally feel like that is also
driving some of the
anger you you looked like you were going
to say something christina yeah i i
think that there's a burn the house down
kind of energy actually in moms that i
know right now across the state it's
anger that we've had the solutions to
fix our buildings to clean the air we
haven't done them
it's anger about the politicization of
public health it's anger that we can't
act collectively to end this thing you
all have different opinions on this
but can you see that what you have in
common is that you are all trying to
make the best decisions for your
families oh absolutely uh you know and i
don't envy anyone having to
make these decisions i think one thing
that we have in common is the amount of
stress that it's placed on parents i
think another layer of this that
sometimes gets overlooked is of course
the pandemic isolated all of us from
each other too so all of these
conversations are not happening
organically at the soccer field or the
pta meeting and you can't have a side
conversation and realize that you do
have some common ground here and there
yeah it's tough for parents out there
saying you guys have little ones mine
are potty trained yeah and one potty
trained and employed
i'm past this stage but i i i i feel for
parents who have to make these decisions
yeah and whether the mask mandates are
lifted in your area or at your school it
is up to the family it is up to the
parent and the child so you know what i
do want to send my kid home with the
mask or send my kid to school with a
mask and if you don't want your kid to
wear a mask and those mass mandates are
lifted shouldn't be judged at all as we
heard from dr jaw one way masking is
effective if you're particularly
vulnerable or particularly concerned you
can wear a mask and provide protection
to yourself and others can make their
own decisions right i think that that is
the future particularly the school
setting yeah
all right thank you for that nora